anyway so you know I just you know
therapy therapy therapy goodbye let me
ask you this now where I do we don't I
don't
okay so so call tan but cancer therapies
at a sponsor that's gonna have you go to
some meetings but he lives in San Diego
I haven't talked to him in like 20 years
cool I still this number though cool
okay and then you're gonna go to some
meeting yeah
and then you're gonna maybe a new
sponsor I was calling this guy texted
this guy that I like a couple weeks ago
remember good it was a guy I liked a
couple of a couple weeks ago there was a
guy I know around in the rooms good I've
always liked him so I texted him I got
do it I'm lost
oh girl and I go can you temporary
sponsor me yeah big text me every day so
I texted him four days in a row and that
didn't do it
after that mm-hmm and then he never
really texted me bash I know he
shouldn't yeah right so it's like some
some resistance here right an
ambivalence resistance it's it's I'm
telling you right now it is the ball and
everything is going toward me getting do
all say anything because it's all I can
just feel well you know the real
question is you have to loser
no for you do anything no is she gonna
have to leave with you loser no no no no
no no no because um it's not fair to her
how long's this been going on I'm asking
her no but I mean that that's been sort
of oh I think he's probably come to head
in the last year so it's many years this
okay roughly speaking yeah yeah hmm so
that's enough
and I told Oliver Hudson this he even
said go to therapy you know all of his a
bunch of therapy right yeah he's a
changed man he's a changed man yeah yeah
and he's like and everyone's telling me
I have to do what I'm not necessarily
telling you go to therapy I'm telling
you to reconnect with your sober peers
that have been important to you see what
they say start going to some meetings
see what happens see if the air clear is
a little bit and once you go cold turkey
and all these things that you're you're
using to regulate your emotions yeah and
see what emerges and maybe something
that really requires therapy will emerge
I don't know yeah it's a lot it's a lot
it's a lot to think I mean if you were
to go to therapy all the therapists
could tell you is
will do [ __ ] stop you have to stop all
this to go to meetings yeah therapy's
gonna die and I will see where you're
right you know yeah honestly see what I
think you know I'm just generally better
off when I'm active in my recovery yeah
no I
yeah I'm just generally more grounded
and more and I am I am what I'm trying
to think of the words they're going all
kinds of different directions but I
would say mostly shocked at that
statement and the way you said it why I
just want you to look back on it again
if you start going to make meetings and
things you're generally you're a don't
see your addiction was life-threatening
and horrible yeah and you're just
generally better when you go to meetings
give me a [ __ ] give me a [ __ ]
break if you were my patient I would I
would be all over you it's not it it's
not right now you're leaning forward
it's not over it's not right for you to
do this I'm not gonna do it I know my
friend I want to say this to you right
okay but for my page you have you going
to do what the [ __ ] what are you talking
you're right okay okay you you made your
point
all right what you did all that the tone
right yeah yeah but here it is I was
flat on my chair
you know 17 you're so lucky to be alive
but anyway go ahead sober for 17 years
Dan involve 17 years survived how'd it
go last time we used to go to meetings
how'd that turn out I went out now but I
almost died but see it's been 17 years
oh so it's gone now it's not God of
course it's not gone okay all right I
know I know that I'm one it's morphing I
know horf them to something else it's
morphing into something else and I know
that I'm in a danger what's mine but
here you know you can admit to this but
drew doctor I'm sorry you drew [ __ ]
please all right [ __ ] that you have to
admit to be this right when you've been
sober for a very long time and you step
away
but you forget yeah right thank you and
in a lot of times you go hey wait a
second you know I'm
haven't been to a meeting and I haven't
relapse yes and I must be normal yeah I
mean that right is just a natural thing
that might occur in your brain but
you're right
I needed a reality check and you just
reality check me and you're right what I
said was crazy [ __ ] do it the way you
did it I did I would have been way worse
super my patient trust me you would have
been a girl are not just anger I would
have I would have whatever came out of
my mouth would have I would have trusted
it and I would have a lot of things
would have flown you cut it for you
because you're my buddy yeah nobody know
here's the thing though it's like you
you know when I knew you were coming
onto the show I didn't know at all that
we were gonna talk about anything
personal and I didn't think it was gonna
but you know it would be funny
and that the people gonna really like
this one well of course it's really good
it's very it's enlightening and you're
in and I want this to work I know and
she worked it together hmm
she and I've said this before she
recreated my career
did you notice he's at an emotional
shift like right now just now yeah what
do you mean your your your better right
now than you were the whole rest upon
you no longer sweating on your nose I
know right I know that I know this yeah
there's many things that I don't know
yeah okay but the things that I do know
is this is that I know that I haven't
taken a drink or drug in 17 years yeah I
know that I am will always be recovering
from my disease these are facts yeah but
I also do know that kalila I believe was
sent into my life I believe that you
know at the time when I met her he
manifested you too so neither of us
really here
[Laughter]
it was it's a perfect timing that you
won't hear and I do know that when I met
her I was in shambles I mean my career I
had nothing going on